le monde de la restauration devra encore
patienter jean castex a confirmé ce
jeudi après midi que les bars et
restaurants ne pourrons rouvrir leurs
portes avant au minimum le milieu du
mois de février
même son de cloche pour les remontées
mécaniques des stations de ski ainsi que
la culture dont les situations seront
réévaluées le 20 janvier
s'agissant du secteur de la culture avec
roselyne bachelot un point de revoyure
début janvier la situation sanitaire que
je viens de vous décrire ne nous permet
malheureusement aucune évolution
aujourd'hui les conditions d'une reprise
à compter de début février seront ainsi
concerter avec les représentants de ces
secteurs que j'ai rencontré à la fin
d'année dernière
nous souhaitons leur donner de la
visibilité en travaillant avec eux à
l'élaboration d'une méthode d'ouverture
encadré et progressive à propos du
couvre-feu à 18h10 autres départements
de l'est de la france pourrait être
soumis à cette mesure
une décision sera prise ce vendredi pour
les départements où le couvre-feu est
fixé à 20 heures cette restriction
durera encore deux semaines à minima au
sujet des vaccins
jean castex et olivier veyrat ont tenté
d'éteindre les critiques concernant la
lenteur de la stratégie de l'exécutif
le ministre de la santé a fixé
l'objectif d'un million de personnes
vaccinées à la fin du mois de janvier
le premier ministre estime de son côté
que la vaccination est désormais la
priorité du gouvernement
le déploiement de la vaccination dessine
une perspective claire de pouvoir sortir
progressivement de cette crise sanitaire
à l'échéance nous l'espérons tous de
l'été prochain pour autant nous allons
devoir vivre avec ce virus encore
plusieurs mois
nous ne baisserons donc pas la garde sur
les gestes barrières les tests ou encore
les mesures de freinage
ce serait irresponsable mais la
vaccination est devenue la priorité
numéro 1 de l'action du gouvernement
nous sommes tous convaincus que c'est la
vaccination la plus large la plus
massive et la plus rapide qui nous
permettra de sortir de la crise si les
effets des fêtes de fin d'année ne
seront observés que la semaine prochaine
l'inquiétude règne autour des deux
nouveaux variants britannique et sud
africain le gouvernement craint que ces
deux formes plus contagieuse du virus 2
propage dans l'hexagone du cluster ont
d'ailleurs été détecté en bretagne et en
ile de france
conséquence la frontière avec le royaume
uni restera fermé jusqu'à nouvel ordre